- Now is a terrible, horrible,
no good, very bad time
to buy a car.
Sure, inflation is slowing down
and supply chains are coming back online,
but now might be the worst
time ever to buy a car,
especially a new car.
There are three big reasons
that Americans who go
car shopping right now
are going to pay more and
get less for their money,
high prices, high demand, poor selection.
I'll explain.
First, let's talk about those high costs.
New car prices are sky high right now.
Five years ago, there were
a dozen new car models
that sold for less than $20,000.
In 2023, there's one.
(car horn honking)
The Mitsubishi Mirage Hatchback.
Whoo, swaging.
It's true that new car
prices have been coming down
since hitting record highs,
but US Treasury yields recently
rose their highest level
in more than 15 years.
We've seen a similar increase
in the rates for auto loans,
and the cost of financing
a car hit an all time high
in the second quarter, so drivers
who financed their vehicle
are actually paying more
than when prices were higher.
Car shopping website, Edmunds,
found that a record 17% of customers
who financed were paying
more than $1,000 a month.
(cash register dinging)
And then there's
insurance and maintenance.
The latest CPI inflation report
showed motor vehicle
insurance costs rose by 19%
from a year ago.
That was the largest increase
of all items in the report.
And just below auto insurance
was the 12% increase in maintenance costs
for cars and trucks.
- [Protesters] Corporate
greed has got to go.
- Oh, and the United Auto
Workers recently announced
a strike at the big three automakers,
so car production could slow even further.
The UAW is seeking a 46% pay
increase over four years,
so this fight could last a while.
And once it's done, car
prices might just go up again.
Car prices are being
held up by high demand,
which means there's a lot
of people trying to buy.
Production slowed down
significantly in recent years,
and that has left a shortage
of millions of new cars.
People didn't just stop needing new cars,
because they weren't being produced,
so folks who couldn't buy
then are trying to buy now.
That's creating something
of a feeding frenzy on lots.
The latest inventory report
from Cox Automotive found
that while inventory has rebounded
from 2021 and 2022 levels,
it has remained low by
historical standards.
And we all know what happens
when there's high demand and low supply,
it's hard for prices
to come down very much.
That lack of production
in recent years also means
that used cars are fewer and
older than in years past.
51% of used cars sold
in the second quarter
were more than three years old.
That's up from 42% before the
pandemic according to Edmunds.
So what's it all mean?
It could mean that now's
a good time to invest
in a nice bicycle or a bus pass.
The latest CPI report
shows new vehicle prices
have fallen in three of
the last five months,
and used car and truck prices have fallen
by more than 6.5% from last year.
So you might wanna wait or
lower your standards a bit.
Whatever you do, now is
definitely not a good time
to buy a new car.
(upbeat music)